Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Cuál es tu signo?
En la astrología occidental es
una constelación determinada por cuando
cae tu cumpleaños en el calendario.
Sin embargo, según el zodiaco chino
o Shengxiao,
es tu shǔxiàng, lo que significa
el animal asignado a tu año de nacimiento.
Y de los muchos mitos que explican los
signos de los animales y su disposición,
el más prevalente es
el de la Gran Carrera.
Según la historia, Yù Dì, el Emperador
de Jade, Rey de los cielos,
quería encontrar una manera de medir
el tiempo, y por eso organizó una carrera.
Los primeros doce animales
en cruzar el río
ganarían un lugar en el calendario
del zodiaco en el orden de llegada.
La rata se levantó al amanecer
para comenzar temprano,
pero de camino al río,
se encontró con
el caballo, el tigre y el buey.
Como la rata era pequeña
y no podía nadar muy bien,
pidió ayuda a los animales más grandes.
El tigre y el caballo se negaron,
el buey, de buen corazón,
aceptó llevar a la rata.
Sin embargo, justo antes
de llegar al otro lado,
la rata saltó de la cabeza del buey
y se aseguró el primer puesto.
El buey quedó en segundo lugar,
con el poderoso tigre justo detrás de él.
El conejo, demasiado pequeño
para combatir la corriente,
ágilmente saltó por piedras
y troncos y llegó de cuarto.
Luego llegó el dragón, que podría
haber volado directamente al otro lado,
pero se detuvo
para ayudar a algunas criaturas
que había encontrado en el camino.
Después llegó el caballo,
a galope a través del río.
Pero en el momento de llegar,
la serpiente reptó hasta allí.
El caballo asustado retrocedió,
dejando que la serpiente
se colara en sexta posición.
El Emperador de Jade, mirando el río
vio la oveja, el mono y el gallo
encima de una balsa,
cooperando juntos para abrirse paso
a través de las malas hierbas.
Cuando llegaron,
el trío acordó dar
el octavo lugar a la oveja,
por haber sido la más
reconfortante y armoniosa de ellos,
seguida por el mono y el gallo.
Después llegó el perro,
luchando hasta la orilla.
Era un gran nadador,
pero retozó en el agua tanto tiempo,
que solo logró llegar undécimo.
El último puesto lo reivindicó el cerdo,
que tuvo hambre y se detuvo
a comer y a echar la siesta
antes de atravesar la línea de meta.
Y así, cada año se asocia con
uno de los animales en este orden,
cuyo ciclo empieza
de nuevo cada 60 años.
¿Por qué 60 y no 12?
Bueno, el calendario chino tradicional
se compone de dos sistemas superpuestos.
Los animales del zodiaco
están asociados con lo que se llama
las Doce Ramas terrestres o shí'èrzhī.
Otro sistema,
los Diez Tallos Celestiales o tiāngān,
está vinculado a
los cinco elementos clásicos
metal, Xin,
madera, mu,
agua, shuǐ,
fuego, huǒ,
y tierra, tǔ.
A cada elemento se le asigna Yin o Yang,
que crea un ciclo de diez años.
Cuando los 12 animales
de las ramas terrestres
se corresponden
con los cinco elementos
más el Yin o Yang
de las ramas celestiales,
crea 60 años de combinaciones diferentes,
conocido como
ciclo sexagenario o Ganzhi.
Así, alguien nacido en 1980
tendrá el signo yang metal mono,
mientras que alguien nacido
en 2007 será yin fuego cerdo.
También puedes tener un animal interno
basado en el mes de tu nacimiento,
un verdadero animal,
basado en su fecha de nacimiento
y un animal secreto
basado en la hora del nacimiento.
Fue la gran carrera la que
supuestamente determinó
qué animales se consagraron
en el zodiaco chino,
pero a medida que el sistema
se propagaba por Asia,
otras culturas hicieron cambios
para reflejar sus comunidades.
Así que si consultas
el zodiaco vietnamita,
puedes descubrir
que eres un gato, no un conejo.
Y si estás en Tailandia,
una serpiente mítica
llamada Naga sustituye al dragón.
Así que si coincide o no
lo que dice el zodiaco
sobre ti como individuo,
lo que es cierto, es que revela mucho
de la cultura de donde provienes.